Good morning everybody.
Welcome. Welcome and thank you so much
for being here this morning. I know that
we have been waiting for this meeting
for a while.
Paqua. Um, it's an honor to have uh
Superintendent Seura. I always call you
Matias. I'm sorry. Yes. And uh some of
the team that has been working on the
plan. Uh I would like to uh give him
some kudos because this is not an easy
job that what what is happening in the
district is not has been easy. But him
given his face in front of meetings, I
appreciate that because I know that it's
probably not very wellreceived in some
places, but I appreciate his his uh
presence today here with us. Uh I also
would like to recognize my staff that is
here that is able to be here because
this is very important to us. If you're
a staff member, would you please stand?
Thank you. These are some of the
teachers. Obviously, not everybody is
here, but this is some of the teachers
have been with me for the last four
years. So, I really appreciate how far
we've gotten to this point. So, thank
you.
>> Good morning, everyone. My name is Ally
Gillarduchi. I'm the senior executive
director of communications community
engagement. I'm just going to go over
our agenda so you kind of know what to
anticipate for our time together. Um, so
we are going to go over some meeting
norms and the purpose of this meeting.
Um, we'll do introductions of the folks
that we have available to answer
questions. Um, we're going to give you
an overview just so that everyone's on
the same page about what we're
specifically recommending that's on the
table right now in terms of changes for
this school. Um, and then we have
pulled, y'all have been filling out, you
see that you have those QR codes on your
tables. That's to the comment card that
we released um on October 3rd. Um, we
pulled out some of the common questions.
There's about five or six that we're
going to kick it off with that we're
going to go ahead and respond to
directly. Um and then we'll just open it
up to a conversation with y'all. We only
have mics that have um cables. So,
unfortunately, if you're going to want
to come and ask a question, we'll
probably need you to come up here. Um
and if you need us to bring it to you,
we can try to figure that out. Um and
then we'll talk about next steps. Um so,
some for our needing norms. Um we want
to build the future together. So, we're
here to acknowledge the challenges in
the current situation while focusing on
ideas and solutions that can make our
district stronger, more equitable, and
sustainable for years to come. That's
really what this process is about. Um,
we want to honor time. So, we're going
to try to keep each speaker to about a
minute. Um, and we're going to try to
keep our responses as brief as possible.
We're not always that good at that. Um,
but we want to make sure that we get
enough time for all of your questions.
Um, we want to honor each other to speak
to one another, not at one another. and
we want to be respectful, avoid
interruptions, personal texts and side
conversations when possible. Um, we want
to honor the process. Um, this meeting
format was thoughtfully developed to
allow space to be able to respond to
things that you've already asked that
we're aware of. Um, as well as to for
you to ask new questions. Um, we want to
honor intent and impact. We know that
we're going to maybe disagree on some
ideas, but we are going to assume
positive intent and focus on our shared
goal, which is a strong, equitable um
school system for all students. Um,
honor, space, and voice. So, if you've
spoken once, we're going to ask that you
allow others to speak who maybe haven't
spoken before we come ask you to speak
again. Um, we want to try to stay
solutionoriented.
Um, and we want to we're in our in being
here today, we're embracing transparency
and empathy. We know these conversations
are difficult. Um, but we want to meet
them with compassion and as much clarity
and honesty as possible.
Um, these are our non in espanol.
Um, and then getting to the purpose. So,
like I said, we want to be able to
respond to some of the questions that
were submitted via the comment card
because these are things that we know
that have come up again and again and we
want to be able to answer those
questions for y'all. Give you an
opportunity also to ask follow-up
questions on those if our responses
aren't clear. Um, we want to gain a
shared understanding of the proposed
changes and the rationale behind them
and then gain we want as leaders to gain
insights that will inform potential
refinements to this draft plan um before
the anticipated vote November 20th.
And with that, I'm going to pass it over
to our leader, Mr. Matia Sigura, to talk
a little bit about the vision.
>> Thank you, Ally. Uh, thank you all for
for being here. Um, I very much
appreciate it. And, uh, before we get
going, I just want to say you I'm sorry.
Um, I know this is a very disruptive
process in general. Anytime when a
community goes through something like
this, it's hard. Um, I I don't want you
to leave this meeting not thinking that
we are doing everything possible to try
to address the concerns around
transition, the disruption this is
causing. Um, I I do want to talk about
kind of where we are as a school
district and what we're trying to
accomplish together.
The first thing I'll say is we as a
school district in Austin ISD have not
been serving our students who've been
historically underserved for a very long
time. This system that's been around for
144 years is designed to produce the
outcomes that we're currently receiving
that we're getting. And so what we need
to do and and what I feel strongly about
is moving to a place where we have
strong neighborhood schools everywhere
in Austin.
Right now we have we have incredible
schools, multicultural, multilingual. We
have schools that have vibrant
communities, but the reality of it all
is that they're not all receiving the
resources they need to be successful.
Well, why is that happening?
Well, it's happening because we as an
organization have so many immense
pressures pushing down on us and we're
having to make decisions at a moment
when our resources are just so so thin.
And so we talk about making a plan and
making a change. Again, we want to have
strong neighborhood schools everywhere
in Austin, accessible to all students.
But to do that, we have to address
several things that are currently out of
alignment,
right? All right. The first thing is
that we have misaligned feeder patterns
in Austin.
I mean, that's the honest truth. You can
go to parts of Austin and you can have a
middle school go wholly into a high
school. Think about what occurs when
that happens. Communities together,
right? The strength of programs, UIL,
all the things are so much stronger. And
that's also true when it's elementary to
middle. We have middle schools right now
in Austin that go to three, four, and
five high schools. Think about that. And
guess where those are?
They're not in West Austin. They're in
East Austin.
So, in order to address that, we have to
change boundaries across a large system
that have been cut into each other for
over a hundred years. two,
our dual language programs, most notably
our wall-to-all dual language programs,
they were they are intended to serve our
emerging bilingual students. That's the
honest truth. That's why they exist.
Now, we as an organization believe in
creating opportunities for all students.
But to do that, we have to ensure that
these programs are stable and
sustainable.
What does that mean? Well, it means that
we need to have a balance of students
who are emerging bilingual and
non-emergent bilingual students. And
what's happened over time, as you know,
because you live in Austin, our
demographics have changed and families
who can no longer afford to live in
Austin are moving further out. And so,
if these programs are to be sustainable,
we need to provide access, which means
we need to go to where they are. And so
you're going to see in this plan as a
second kind of element are is moving of
our wall-to-wall de language programs.
The third thing we absolutely have to
address the inefficiencies or the
misalignments in our system. Like right
now the cost of education is increased.
Our enrollment has declined because of
affordability in Austin. Right? We're
getting hit right now
based due to federal changes. We're down
2,000 students this year. Immigrant
families who are not coming to AISD and
immigrant families who have left. When
you look at where those students are,
where they're located, that's that
population. So, I need you to know there
are many, many things putting pressure
on our system right now and we're
desperately trying to move forward
together so that we can maintain local
control. The other thing we have to do,
we have to become more efficient. You
just heard me talk about the reduction
in enrollment, the the pressures from
the federal level at the federal level,
the freezing up of funds. These things
are real. And so right now, the reality
of it all is that we cannot continue to
operate the way we are without
introducing
significant financial risk downstream in
the future. And let me be clear,
financial risk in Austin, in our school
districts is right up there with
accountability risk, special education
delivery risk. All of these things have
to be managed and supported
or else we in, you know, we lose the
ability of educating our students in a
way that we believe is most appropriate
and align with our values. The other
thing I want to communicate is our
transfer policies have been
just a buildup of lots of decisions over
many many decades. And right now we have
students who are being drawn away from
parts of Austin going to other schools.
Why is that happening? Some people say
it's because well we don't have high
performing schools in these communities.
Well to do that we need stability. We
need resources.
The other element is that our transfer
policies are allowing that movement to
occur and are drawing students away from
these communities. So, we have to be
honest about that. What is the long-term
impact of these transfers?
And so, as a school district, we have to
do all of this while addressing one of
the most timerestrictive elements, which
is accountability.
It's not lost on me that in this
community, we 100% believe that our
students are way more than a letter
grade. I believe that. I know that you
believe that. But we have to operate in
a state that uses an assessment taken on
one day in the year to determine,
you know, whether our schools are strong
or not. And so all of this has to be
balanced. In order for us to move
forward, we have to acknowledge that. We
have to make difficult decisions because
if we don't there is the real potential
for the state to come in and intervene
and that is something I am not going to
allow to have happen. I'm not going to
do it right because if that happens all
of our students 70,000 plus of them are
not going to be guided in their
educational journey by those who live in
this community.
and don't just know this is real. It's
happening right now to our sister school
district in North Texas.
So, I just
we very much love I very much love this
school district. I love our students. We
are at a moment where we have to change.
Uh this change here uh with Dawson uh is
one that is part of a large plan uh
which I just um highlighted a couple
elements of. you go to the next slide.
But what this plan includes for Dawson
is for all the students at Dawson to go
wholly into Galindo.
And so one of the things that we talk
about when we talk about student
movement is making sure that the entire
student cohort, all the students move
together so that families are kept
together, so that friends are kept
together.
We also need to get our schools to have
a healthier enrollment so that we can
provide the resources campus by campus
to make sure that our students get what
they what they need to be academically
successful and just successful in
general. I mean there are lots of things
that we as a school district pay for
that are not required by the state,
right? We pay for librarians, we pay for
registered nurses,
right? These are things that we believe
in. we procure our own curriculum. We
could save seven eight million dollars
if we decided to use a state curriculum.
But I promise you that wouldn't align
with who we are.
So the plan uh includes Dawson moving
wholly into Galindel. Uh because of um
the accountability um chain that exists.
Uh what that means is Galinda will
receive the turnaround plan and then
we'll work together to break that
accountability chain. And so um I guess
you me tackle this real quick then I'll
hand it off.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> So no it's okay. We'll stay here. The um
you heard me talk about one of the
pressures of the of the accountability.
Uh we have to just acknowledge that that
Dawson has three UAS,
right? UA is an abbreviation for the
state uses for unacceptable
accountability. They did that. Doesn't
make any sense the way that it's
written, but it's that's what it means.
And so what that means is you have
either three Fs or three Ds and two Fs,
some combination that ultimately get to
three UAS. Now, I want to be really
clear. This is not our students fault.
It's not. We as a school district have
been coming out of a period of
disruption where we're trying to get to
a stable system, but for the last many
years, it hasn't been the case. And so,
as we come out, we have to break that
accountability chain. And so, what that
means is that the principal or the new
leader of that campus, I mean, the the
campus leader will take the TAP plan
from Dawson to Galindo. Uh, we will have
a very specific hiring plan. It's one
that's required by the state of Texas.
It's a we have to define how many years
of experience must an educator have to
be in that school. Um, you know, are
there certifications, TIA, TIA
designations or nally board certified
teachers that are going to be pulled
into part into that plan? Um, I also
want to be really clear that if we can
break the accountability chains across
the district, we will move ourselves
into a place where our academic outcomes
and our pursuit of them will be aligned
with our values. If we do not break
these chains, right, the interventions
or what the state requires us do gets
harder and harder and more rigid year
after year. That's the honest truth. And
so we're at a moment now where we're
trying to do all of this together um as
an entire school district. Uh and so
with that, I'll I'll hand it over to I
think Christine to probably take us
through the next couple questions.
>> Yeah, we can talk about it. You have
Christine.
>> Yeah, it's a pretty simple one.
>> Thank you. Um thank you, Superintendent
Sigura. My name is Christine Steinport.
I'm the operations officer for Austin
ISD. Um just wanted to kind of take you
through, you've probably seen these
before in the draft deliverable. These
are our boundaries. So the existing
boundary for Dawson there you could see
on the right and so um the like
superintendent Siguro was saying um we
want to keep communities together as
much as possible and some of these other
plans for other schools it's not always
possible depending on the boundaries
depending where our schools are and then
how many seats we have available at
those schools but um just wanted to kind
of showcase that right there. Um Ally if
you want to move forward. Um, oh, sorry.
Well, then I think we went out of order,
but um, now we can start and really get
to the meat of things and go through the
comment cards. Um, there were a few
there were a lot of, um, comments and so
Ally and her team distilled those down
and so we'll get to those right now.
Um, so the first comment we had and this
came from m multiple commenters was
instead of closing Dawson, can you
consider moving the Becker program to
Dawson because this campus is located on
a major thoroughfare and affordable
housing is going up to densify the
neighborhood.
Yeah, I'll start um and then I'll pass
it over to my colleague. So, um, really
down to looking at, and I know I just
said this previously, but it's really
looking at where students reside and how
many schools we have around there. And
so, we have a lot of um, we have a lot
of empty seats. We have more schools
than we have students in those areas.
And so, I wanted to kind of touch on
what Superintendent Sagura said earlier
about the intent of the dual language
program and the wall-to-wall there. Um,
and so I'll pass it off to you Cardennis
to kind of talk us through what that
wallto-wall at Becker looks like, um,
and why that program is moving.
>> Thank you so much. So, good morning.
Thank you for being here this morning.
Um, to talk about this question in
particular, we've talked about again the
intent of our bilingual education
programs or dual language. And so when
we look at the location that's being
proposed for the Becker dual language
program, there is about 68% emergent
bilingual students in that area. When we
look at um Dawson right now, which is an
amazing school, Dawson has about 26 27%
emergent bilingual students here. And so
again, thinking about locations where um
a larger number of emergent bilingual
students live and the sustainability of
the program that was definitely one of
the conver uh considerations on this.
I think I'm getting so sorry I'm getting
the impression maybe that this was not
an ask from the Dawson community. Yeah.
Okay. Well, it was in the comment card,
but so we'll go ahead and move on.
>> Got it. Okay. So, I honestly love how
they're treating my kids and teaching
them. I just wish that they wouldn't
close Dawson. What were the factors that
led to the decision to close Dawson when
it's been around for generations? And
that's from Kim D.
I think it's just it's what I kind of
touched on earlier. It's not any
specific thing. It's everything in
general. It works together. So, if you
looked at the plan, it was not just
because a school is old or in poor
condition. We had the rubric. We started
there. We saw misalignments, but then we
had to really work with where students
live, how many buildings we have, where
those are located, where students live,
and then looking at our boundaries as
well. So, it was a multifactored
layer cake, if you will, when we did
that. I know Superintendent Sigura also
talked about feeder patterns and and
making those more aligned. That is
another layer. So, there's elementary to
middle, middle to high. And so, there
were many other factors. It wasn't just
one specific thing. It was all working
together for the greater system to make
sure that we could balance enrollment.
Um we could um you know align feeder
patterns and all those other things.
Superintendent, do you have something?
>> So So I think one thing that um we look
at when you look at a cluster of schools
uh and you look at each school
specifically is how many students live
there now and based on our demographic
report, how many will likely live there
in the next 5 10 years. And one of the
things that we know about this community
is that it's changed in that currently
we're about 25 to 27% resides. Meaning
that if every single student in this
area picked Dawson, we would still only
be about 27 28% utilized, right? Which
means that your costs per student goes
through the roof. And so as a system,
you know, right now we're about what 160
180 students enrollment. Well, when you
get to a school that um isn't quite have
the critical like student population, it
really impacts us from a um academic
programming perspective um when it comes
to uh fidelity of be able to support our
educators. And I know that having small
schools uh has many like great like
benefits, but we just can't operate that
many of them. And so when you think
about where we need to position schools,
you really want to position schools that
have an attendance boundary that
collectively have a higher number of
students that live in. And that's just a
function of just how the city's changed
around us. You know, our schools don't
move, but people do move. And um so
that's one of the things that I would
say that drove kind of this plan to
consolidate Dawson into Galindo was that
now we'll have collectively a larger
attendance boundary that has that um
foundation of students been able to
support a healthy student population for
years to come. Roughly 75% once combined
which is which is really where you'd
like to be.
Can you tell us anything um could you
tell us anything you can about what will
happen to the building and how we can
begin the process of trying to have any
sort of community involvement for the
space? That's from Kim M.
>> Yeah. So, um great question. So, first
off, um we did not make any decisions
based on the location or real estate
value. I've had that be a comment like
Matis, did you make a vote? Because
that's not what this was. This is really
intended to develop a plan based on our
guidelines and our overall um kind of
strategy. As we move forward, if this
plan is approved on November 21st, one
of the things that we'll do is build
out, we have it already framed uh is our
engagement plan to support each school
transition facility-wise.
I do not want to have a shuttered
building. That is not what this is
about. That's not what I would have um
or what I would recommend. Uh so
typically what we would do and we do
have this built out. It's in a couple
different um approved uh um agenda items
from our trustees. We uh identify what
is community benefit. Um our board in
2019 took a vote that said if you're
going to repurpose pol uh properties,
ensure that there's a community benefit
and they actually defined what community
benefit was. It was teacher housing, it
was affordable housing, it was open
space, it was community space. uh there
were I think two or three other elements
of that. So since then, we've used that
framework to progress um uh a couple
different properties that have
transitioned. And what we're going to do
now is revisit the entire process and
say, okay, you know, we're going to
engage. This is what engagement is going
to look like. There may be um there's
going to be this this kind of a
iterative process where we get to a
final recommendation. I will tell you
it's really going to depend on the
community's desire to either increase
the the time in which this occurs or
decrease it. We're very sensitive to
sometimes communities acknowledging
that, hey, this was a a loving school.
If you go and and go through a trans
transaction too quickly, it's going to
feel a certain way. Um, so we slow those
down. In some cases, we've pushed them
up. It really depends on this community.
We will not do anything without y'all's
voice in the process. Our board expects
it. I expect it. Our policies and
procedures right now include it. Um you
will see in our next deliverable to the
board a an update to our um our process
just because right now it lives in like
four different spots and we're going to
consolidate it down to one page. Uh so
as far as as how quickly we can we go,
we can go as quickly as this community
wants. Um but I will say that in years
past there's been a sensitivity of going
too quickly. But if we heard here, hey
Matias, this is something we want to do
to make sure it remains a vibrant kind
of hub in our community. We want to
start this process. Then we would start
that process with you. But I want to be
honest with kind of what's happened in
the past.
>> Yeah. So um one of the ones, so there's
been a couple. So P's Elementary School,
which closed in 2019, uh the desire from
the community and the neighborhood
association was to ensure that we had um
children still in the building. uh we
couldn't operate it, but what we did is
we worked with Congressman Dogget's
office. We actually got a grant. Uh
we're able to make some improvements and
then do uh a deal with United Way and
now it's an early childhood center. It's
perfect. So, they have an operating
agreement with us. We own the property.
There's children in it uh and children
and programming that aligns with our
school district. Uh but it doesn't it
doesn't it's not a building that I have
to operate and maintain. So, the cost is
negligible. Another one um would be
Anita Koy. Anita Koi is a little bit
different. Uh it's a property that that
has been closed um a school that's been
closed for many many many years now, but
we have had um the alternative learning
center on that site. And what we've
decided to do is to move forward with a
teacher housing and workforce housing
project that blends uh kind of various
levels of median family incomes. Uh it's
a 650 unit project. And again, one of
the things that I tell people is, you
know, we have to acknowledge that this
city is pushing because of affordability
families out. And if we have the ability
to help offset that in some way, we need
to consider it. That project has already
been um uh inked uh the public
facilities corporation which is built
and it kind of runs in parallel with our
trustees uh and our and our school board
um have has approved that contract and
we're moving forward. The other one uh
that I would say is um there's a couple
others, Mets and Brooke. I will tell you
that right now, this is an example of
going maybe too fast. Uh the community I
would say at the time didn't want to
think about or didn't want to move
forward with the process. So we actually
used it as a hub for staff to support
the 2022 bond program. So once the bond
program was passed at $2.4 billion, we
didn't want more people at central
office. we really wanted them out at the
projects and that served as a very
appropriate kind of satellite work
office and it also kept our general
contractors from having to actually rent
space. So, we're able to save money in
that way. So, there are lots of ways
that we can do this. Um, we always take
the lead from the community. Uh, but
those are just a couple examples that
have already occurred or in the process.
>> Yeah. So, that's another that's another
good example. Um so there are um lots of
projects that are currently underway and
one of the things that we've done also
is use the schools as a swing space um
for uh modernized projects modernization
projects or in the event that a school
goes down um like last year we had um
Keeling Middle School it went had a fire
the first day first couple first week of
school in those in some instances we can
move an entire school uh in some cases
we can't in that case we weren't able to
do so But if we have a facility that we
can operate and run, we can have
professional development in it. There's
things that we can do and then in the
event there's an emergency or a swing
space solution, we can move a whole
entire school into that space. Right now
we have whole schools in portable
villages uh to kind of address the off
the swing space solution to some of
these projects. This would this could be
an example of that helping us in that
way as well and reducing cost.
Okay, this is the last presubmitted
question we have. Um, this one says,
"The dual language program at Dawson is
an asset to our community. We don't want
to lose this valuable part of our
children's growth, development, and
sense of belonging. Can you pause and
evaluate lower risk alternatives that
protect stability by literacy gains and
trust across South Austin?" That's from
Patricia V.
Hi, thank you for that question. Um, so
Galindo does have a dual language
program. You've got approximately 59
students right now currently at Dawson
that are participating in dual language.
Next year that'll be about 49 um
students moving into Galindo. So they
have a wellestablished dual language
program at Galindo and we would be able
to welcome students from Dawson into
that program.
Okay. So now um we can What time are we
at?
8:30. We are scheduled to be here till
9:30, so we have about an hour for any
questions that y'all have. Um, so you're
welcome if you'd like to come up to the
mic. Um,
um, we do need to because we're
recording it for anyone who couldn't
come and if you're not speaking into the
mic, it's not going to be caught on the
on the recording.
Okay. [laughter]
Is this one working? Yeah. Okay. Well,
and it's it's more of a comment than a
question, but it's a chance um and I'm
probably not saying anything you don't
already know, but it's a chance for you
to hear from us. And first, I just want
to say that Dr. Goodiness, Dr. Garcia,
and the entire staff here have done a
wonderful job. And
[applause] you had mentioned it's not,
you know, it's not the students fault
with the accountability ratings. We
understand that it's not their fault
either. They're dealing with, and again,
you know this, but they're dealing with
societal forces well outside of their
control. So, from a parental standpoint,
we would like to just say that they've
done an excellent job serving our kids.
My daughter's in first grade here, and
we couldn't be happier with what she's
received.
>> Yeah. Thanks. So, um
thank you. That's um
that I mean that's I just Thank you. Um
one of the things that I I want our
community to know is we are desperately
trying to get to be a stable, loving,
welcoming, trustbased school district.
Um you know, I'll tell you when we came
out of the pandemic, as we moved uh into
the succession of leaders, we had three
within like three three within two
years. uh that has a huge impact. You
know the correlation between
superintendent and principal, principal
and teacher, it it is huge. And uh my
first year in I hired I think 27
principles. We only have 116. Like how
how can you ever get to stability when
your attrition rate is that high? And
that was a function of a lot of the
openings that had were kind of existed
that I needed to get through. You you're
right. We have been able to place
incredible leaders and we're seeing that
system respond. You know, it's not lost
on me that yeah, there are some schools
that have three UAS, but the the
progression is is like it is very very
uh significant. And we see that
unfortunately the state still sees three
UAS. And so you bring a a really good
point that I I kind of want to reinforce
and that is our principal, our staff,
our teachers are everything. They are um
I've been really clear about our
approach to protect our teachers,
protect our staff. That's everybody from
the principal to the custodian to the
food service worker to our teacher
teacher assistants. Uh our plan um
creates a process that allows our
educators and staff to find a home. Um,
it is my intention to make sure that
there are familiar faces wherever our
students go. So, you can imagine what
that's going to look like, especially
when we think about bringing schools
together. And we will find a home for
everybody that wants to be in Austin
ISD. That's clear. There have been
comments made uh that I I'm very
disappointed in where someone says,
"Well, Matias, you must been looking at
like, you know, contracts or this or
that." Like, that has never even crossed
my mind ever. Uh, we love our teachers.
Um, my mom was a teacher for here for 40
years. is like I'm a product of the
school district. My kids come here. Like
that that is not something I'm going to
do. Um so I appreciate you sharing that.
Um and I there are incredible things
happening. We just have to get through
this together. Um and I'm going to do
everything possible to support all of
y'all in this transition, whatever it
may look like. I mean, that's the honest
truth. It's still a draft plan. But
thank you for that comment. Very much
appreciate it.
>> Hi, thanks for coming today. I'm Kristen
Brown. I have two kids here at Dawson.
Um, I've lived in the neighborhood for
11 years and seen the school go through
its transition. I'll be a little more
direct than Josh and say that the
community, we reject the the Scarlet tap
um that's being put on here. We think
that, you know, there was more time
actually the school's been under a tap
and her name is Dr. Dolores Codinez. Um,
and without those extra resources, the
school has nearly turned itself around.
I think you'll see that in the scores
this year. Um, but you know, we
understand where we all are and this is
happening. So, um, you just mentioned
it, but I' I'd like it to be reiterated.
How are you going to protect our
administration and teachers? They all
have guaranteed jobs, even those that
are in the process of certification.
>> Yes.
>> And then [clears throat] I have a
follow-up question about the facility.
>> So, so um, in the process Yeah. So,
thank you for putting that up. Uh, so in
the process of certification, yes. Uh,
one of the things that that we have to
be responsive to is the state of Texas
has changed the law. I'm not sure how
many of our families know this, but
moving forward, we will not be able to
have non-certified teachers in our
classrooms, period. Right now, about 12%
of our educators are non-certified
moving towards certification. And some
of them, we use uh, you know, a district
of innovation to to create some
flexibility. So what that means is that
here at into next year and certainly the
following year, I will be required by
law to make moves in a school district
that ensure that every student has a
certified teacher or has a teacher that
is making progress in their journey to
become certified. Uh because I want to
make that distinction because right now
there are lots of educators that have
that are in that have been working have
been doing great work uh but haven't
made quite made that progression. Uh and
as we move forward where this becomes
even more salient is with our
wall-to-wall dual language programs. So
if we have students and our current
policy is 18 emerging bilingual students
in our elementary schools. If we have
that number we will um ensure that we
have a dual language certified educator
like in that space. Uh the reality of it
all is that if we don't have the numbers
talk about wall-to-wall do language
moving then the number of students u
will require by law fewer educators but
what that also means is where I have
higher number of emerging bilingual
students I will have to ensure that we
have certified teachers and I will tell
you that we are all all our school
district every school district around us
competing for certified dual language
educators um so so That's just one kind
of point. I do want to highlight this
document which is uploaded on October
3rd. It includes our commitment in
milestone form as well as plan form how
we're going to support our educators. Um
you're right, every plan will be
slightly different because Galinda will
receive a the tap from Dawson. Uh it'll
look slightly different if you go down
as a flowchart. Um,
>> so just to repeat, every single teacher
here at Dawson who is I guess in good
standing or whatever that is who's in
the process of certification has a job
within AISD.
>> Yes. If they choose to stay.
>> If they choose to stay.
>> And then the accelerated supports you're
giving our staff here for those that are
in that process are are what what
additional career services and support
are they receiving?
>> Yeah. So that's going to be um Brandy
Hosek or our our talent strategy
division would be able to give you the
specifics. I can't speak to specifics as
far as what supports you provide. Um I
know the plans. I know generally
speaking as a district what we provide.
Um I can't speak to specifically kind of
what resources have been deployed here.
Um I can certainly uh get back with the
team and and you know the lotus you know
we can talk about it. I just can't speak
specifically to like teachers here. Um,
>> okay. That's super important to this
community. Unlike some other schools
that are being closed, we're not
spending money hiring lobbying groups to
try to keep our unsustainable school
open. This is very important to the
community that the administrators and
teachers are supported staff.
>> Um, my second issue is about the safety
and security of when a school closes.
So, we are where we are in Austin. It is
of paramount importance that this school
is safe that there is an increased
police presence of of the a what's that
>> or occupancy it is extremely important
and as someone who I live directly
across the street from the playground
this is a critical issue we need to know
exactly what the plan is of how the
school will be kept securely and and
safe. Even if there is a transition, I
mean, I'm sure you're aware it's worth
$70 million. Um, if you haven't
considered that, frankly, that's it's
kind of crazy that, you know, I mean,
it's a very valuable property. So, I
hope that there actually are development
plans or at least multiple streams of
development plans in play. Um, and I
appreciate the sentiment that the
community will be involved, but this is
very, very, very important that you are
being mindful of what this can do to a
neighborhood that this that is this
close that deals with so many community
factors. Um, so I'd love to hear about
what the security plan has been and how
you've dealt with it at other campuses
that have been temporarily not occupied.
>> Yeah. No, we've we've dealt with it um
along our journey for sure. Uh so just
to be clear um even though it may not be
occupied in the sense that it's a school
it's still a school that a facility that
we will operate and maintain right so
grass mode you know electrical will will
run through and make sure that
everything is working. We do not just
leave a building vacant and shuttered.
Um I hope that you've seen that uh in as
we've gone through this over the last
couple years. I can't think of a school
where that's occurred. Typically what
we'll do um is we'll uh the school
itself right now reports under our
talent and strategy portfolio. So it's
by our principal principal all the way
up through since and so TLL teaching
learning leading effectively kind of
runs the campus at the point that it
transitions into uh a non-educationbased
camp facility. It'll actually move under
Christine Steampport our operations
officer. And so when that occurs, uh
there's a director there who has a uh
the portfolio of all the other
properties. It includes, you know, the
the bus terminals. It includes other
properties that are not schools. And uh
there's a schedule of maintenance and
assessments that occur continuously
throughout the year. We will also um if
so, it kind of goes both ways. We we
will also place staff there to kind of
in because we we're we have staff that
are on hybrid. we're trying to reduce
our overall cost. Um, I do not want to
rent space if I can ever do that. So, if
there's a a way for us to move staff
here in order to free up another
facility, then we may consider it for a
short-term basis. The counter position
that I've heard before is, you know,
you're moving staff here. You know,
you're just going to do X, Y, or Z. So,
whatever we do, I want to be really,
really clear with you what it's going to
look like. Um, regarding our, uh, police
department presence, that will be the
same as it is now. you won't have an SRO
designated to this campus. Um, but you
will have someone designated to the zone
coming by periodically throughout the
day walking. We have protocols around
that, accessing the building, walking
every hall. Uh, our security um systems
will continue to go and be online. Those
do not stop. Uh, as far as fencing and
kind of um lockup procedures, that's
really a community conversation. you
know, we have schools right now that are
um kind of maintained very open uh you
know, security systems, meaning like the
you know, the fencing will be open
throughout the weekends and in the
evenings and in the mornings and then we
have other communities that have a
slightly different approach mainly
because of what they're seeing occur
like on the site and you can imagine
where those might be. So, uh we have
lots of flexibility in how to do that. I
will tell you that we have done it
before. We're prepared to do it. We have
protocols around it. um we can come back
at the appropriate time and share with
you precisely what it's going to look
like procedurally. Um but we do have
those in place as far as SOPs. We just
don't finalize them until they go
through an operations review and a
police review based on the specifics of
the campus. Um and again it's different
if it's occupied for that short period
of time. Um now the comment around $70
million and it's it's you know why I
didn't consider that. Well, because a
lot of times uh it it's that's obviously
based on highest and best use um not
based on what we can probably accomplish
and what is meets the intent of the
community. I would never want to put a
number out there that I know we will not
be able to to get. Um and I'm always
looking at long-term um capitalized
ground leases versus fee simple
transactions. Right? I I you I want to
make sure that as we manage our
portfolio of resources as a school
district, we do not unload property like
I mean why would anybody ever do that?
But if we can find a partner where we
can develop or we can repurpose and then
we keep it in our portfolio for the next
50 100 years and then at the some point
in the future if it needs to revert back
to a campus we have that ability. If we
lose it we will lose it forever. Um so
so that's why it's never something that
I lead with. Um, certainly I'm aware of
all the things, you know,
portfolio-wise, but it's not something
that comes in the calculus because you
could make an argument like, well, why
don't you sell Austin at high? You could
pay for all your debt like that. People
tell me that all the time. Well, you
know, that's that's it doesn't work that
way, but that's how we would approach
it. And so, maybe what we can do is at
the appropriate time come back and have
a specific meeting with the neighborhood
and with the community around what it's
going to look like if we're at that
point after the vote. Would that be
helpful?
>> I just I mean, I think it'd be good to
see exactly.
>> Okay. And I just want to go back to the
first question you had because I was
going to try to pull up Oh, did you get
it up?
>> Okay. The the ASD network might be down.
We're having connectivity issues, but we
wanted to talk about because you had
talked about specifically what resources
are going to go into supporting these
schools. So, we have a slide um if you
scroll down, it's the one that has the
two pie charts that shows it's pretty
far down, but what shows the
approximated savings from this plan. Um,
and it's about 25.6 million is what we
believe that we're going to the
efficiencies that we're going to gain
from it. Um, but you'll also see there's
another slide after it. Let me see. Keep
going. There it is. Um, yeah. So, that
shows you that 25.6 million in the
breakdown. Um, but if you'll go I guess
I have a clicker now. Um,
we also are planning on reinvesting in
students. And so each school that has a
turnaround plan, we are budgeting an
average of $800,000 for new staff
positions um such as and this can be as
he said like the campus can kind of
tailor to figure out what where they
think the need is. But it can fund
things like assistant principles, extra
counselors, instructional coaches who
support your instructors, content
interventionists who support students
who maybe need um more um exposure to
the content to go over it again. and
then possibly even lowering the student
teacher ratios at that campus. Um, did
you have a followup?
>> It goes to the combined any school next
year that has a turnaround plan.
>> So, just to be clear, we we have we've
we have changed how we approach our
support of our schools in the last two
and a half years. Um I I know that it's
not as clear as like this one injection,
but I want to be really honest about
what we've done. Right? So two and a
half years ago, um we did not have
instructional coaches around the entire
school district. We had them
sporadically at some schools that offset
them with title one dollars
with with speaking
>> sorry um instructional coaches. So that
was 23 24. Then we created minimums. So,
one of the things that happened is our
trustees and I sat and said, "If you
just use staffing allocations, you're
going to get to a point where you have
half an AP or you have, you know, you're
sharing a PE teacher or a music." So,
that's so we created a floor. So, that's
something that most people don't know.
We created a floor and we also ensured
that you had um supports uh and a
minimum of two teachers per grade level.
So, one of the things that happens is if
your student enrollment goes down to
150, 140, you can get to a place pretty
quickly where you might only have one
teacher per grade level. Well, that is
not where you want to be, right? You
want to have the collaboration. You want
teachers to work with one another,
create a team. And so, we said, we're
going to make a minimum. So, that only
applied to a handful of schools that had
populations around this size. Then, we
came back around in 23 24 and said, we
need instructional coaches. I mean sorry
we need content interventionists because
we have students that are not on grade
level and our educators are working so
hard but to get all of our educators all
of our students back on grade level we
have to deploy content interventionist
so that was a 2020 for tax rate
election. So that was the commitment we
made. So that all came in then we came
back and created um supports based on
the turnaround plans and the projected
taps for uh the 23 24 and 25. So there's
been there's been resources deployed. Um
I I I want to be really really clear.
>> We know we're very well informed about
what's been given. What's what is Dawson
getting this year to ensure success for
the students that are here this year?
Now
>> well that's going to be a convers I mean
I specifically I I I don't want to
misspeak. Um I I will tell you that we
follow our lead. I follow our lead from
our principles, our executive directors.
we create a framework and a and a
baseline like this is what all these
schools are going to receive and then
there's some autonomy locally to figure
out okay what does that specific campus
need um regarding kind of what needs to
be um supported or what resources need
to be deployed between now and the
remainder of the year that's a
conversation that either is about to
take place hasn't take place maybe you
know our executive director can speak to
it um I don't want to misspe and say
it's this and this when it might be
something different um do you want to
speak to that
Hello everyone. I'm Sandre McWills. I'm
the executive director that supports
Dawson. Uh during leveling this year, we
did have some conversations and input
from Dr. Gulinish regarding some of the
positions here. So there was a position
or two that was left um held harmless.
So that normally during the typical
leveling process, those teachers are
removed based on the number. this year
that didn't happen. We also provide
support uh through professional
development with TNTP and the learning
labs. Um I come twice a week and visit
with Dr. Godinz to see what her needs
are and then based on her needs I deploy
those um resources here to Dawson. I've
sat in um several PLC meetings with her
instructional coach uh Susan back there.
And then we do um a feed observation and
feedback cycle to help with the teachers
develop and capacity and their practices
and ensure that they have the resources
they need to be successful this year.
Those are just the beginnings. Um we're
now in the process of now that we have
some data collected through map growth.
We're looking at that and also seeing
what other additional resources we can
provide to help the students be
successful and break the chain here.
>> Do you want to did y'all do you all know
what lighthouse school is? Have you
heard that term before?
>> Okay. You have?
>> Because I know you weren't chosen last
year.
>> Yeah. So, um, so what, uh, our
lighthouse schools are and our
laboratory schools, it's a it's a
network of support that we deployed last
year. Um, and it's one that started with
our schools that were actually
um, tied to um, turnarounds or taps that
even were more excessive or further
along. Um the original initial
investment uh was one that was done in
partnership with the education fund and
Austin ISD. And the way that it works is
we have a partner that helps us
understand you know are our educators
using the curriculum. Um are we
supporting them in kind of growing their
skill set to ensure implementation of
that curriculum and then are we having
are we ensuring that our principles are
the um uh instructional leaders on their
campuses. Uh that was a big deal because
you know our in the years past what was
happening was our academics team was
doing professional development with our
teachers but what really needed to
happen was our principles needed to
become the educational leaders or the
academic leaders so they could see in
real time and make adjustments and
support their educators. So we have
lighthouse schools each lighthouse
school has a clustering of observation
schools uh we call them lab schools and
what they do is they all round together
and they learn together. So our
principles will work together. They'll
go visit a campus which is the
lighthouse campus. They'll then take
back to their own campus their
observations and learnings and then TNTP
our partner also provides support. So
we've seen significant movement. I mean
our early literacy early numeracy
numbers are are moving um very
aggressively in the correct direction
which is very very promising. Um so
that's the structure. We just didn't
have the resources last year to roll it
out um districtwide. Um, so this year an
expansion of the partnership and
recognizing that it's working, we went
ahead and made that commitment. Uh, but
that's what it is and it's it's working.
Uh, it's a very very different approach
than what we've done in the past. Uh,
but it is working.
>> I just want to add um it is a little bit
of a situation of maybe too little too
late. I think in terms of what you were
saying earlier is that tea still sees
those three Fs. But I do want to just
point out we had I was just looking at
the data last night. We have, I think it
was nine schools that were one point
away from an F to a D and we had seven
that were one point away from a D to a
C. And these are schools that, you know,
previously they were in maybe in the
40s. Um, and there's a difference
obviously between like a for a score of
40 and a score of like 59. That's like
right on the edge. It's not where we
want to be, but the it's clear that the
trajectory has been moving in the right
direction. It's just not as fast as TEA
expects.
>> Go ahead.
>> Sorry.
>> Hi. My uh daughter attended Dawson some
years ago and um I live in the
neighborhood. I'm involved with the
neighborhood association and I'm here to
talk about community engagement because
we are definitely going to be um there's
a an avid interest amongst folks even
though their kids are long gone from
Dawson in uh the school and the
property. Um, I'm very happy to hear
that, um, there is some talk of keeping
the green space available for public use
because that is one of the things that
our neighbors have enjoyed. And I'm also
very happy to hear that safety is of
primary interest because those those go
together. Um, I would like to ask ask
about how the condition of facilities is
being weighed. Um, for those of us
who've been around a long time, there
was the Fab Pack which
>> looked you were part of that. Oh, so you
probably have bad dreams about that.
>> Um,
>> that was that was an interesting time
and uh, condition of facilities was part
of that process. Um, many of us have
driven by and seen the signs that say
your bond money at work fixing the
school. So, seeing this building torn
down, I think a lot of people would
never ever vote for another school bond
if they thought that the uh recently um
you know that their money was being
wasted and the building was being torn
down. Um, so so yes. Um,
>> yeah. So, the couple things. Um, I get
this from time to time and I was on the
I supported the fat pack, supported the
2022 bond program, a tax rate election.
I I was kneede in in all of those
things. The first thing I would say is
um the 2017 bond was based on work in
2015 2016 that was done with the fat
pack. Uh, and that's also true of the
2022 long range plan that ultimately led
to the 2022 bond, which you know, which
is what we're kind of working through
now. What I would tell people is if you
cannot make decisions based on what you
don't know, uh, at that time, did we
think that the 20 the 88th legislature
was not going to fund public education?
I mean I I mean I that was a big big big
I would say um
uh shared understanding of over a
thousand school districts. We were
hemorrhaging money. Did we think that
you know the vouchers and the way all
that worked would be kind of would be
run and compete against school funding?
I don't know that I could have said
that. The other thing I would say is we
didn't want to be here and if things had
have changed differently after those
milestones, we probably wouldn't. Um,
that being said, if someone ever argues
you spent money on a building where
there are kids in it, I would say,
"Yeah, that's what you need to be
doing." Um, if a building I I want to
make sure our students have working AC.
I want to make sure water is working.
That costs money. If someone would say,
"Well, don't spend that money." And then
all of a sudden I'm going to hear the
other position which is why are you
leaving our students without AC or
without what they need? So if our
students are in a building we're going
to put the money forward. Now we want to
be very thoughtful. We're not going to
to do something that we maybe should
delay but generally speaking if a
student is in a building we're going to
make sure that they're safe, that
they're comfortable, that they have the
environment to learn. Um, I have no
problem having that conversation because
at the time that we asked our voters for
it, you could not have imagined that the
pressures would have escalated the way
that they have and that um we would be
where we are now. Uh, and the honest
truth is many of those projects are
still going forward. The $2.4 billion,
the vast majority of that will still be
constructed. uh the vast majority and
you look at our ability to build and our
efficiencies of construction, compare
that to any other public entity and I
would think you'd find that they're very
very efficient and we produce very very
high quality buildings. But that's just
my take on it.
>> Thank you.
>> Of course.
>> Okay. Hi Carrie Freeman. I'll be very
kind, as kind as I can be, but very
clear. So, thank you Kristen for already
addressing one of our major concerns was
the talent and the teacher and the
individuals that have done so many
instrumental and amazing things for our
children. Um, it bears repeating that
our administration here is superb. As a
recovering AISD administrator and
bilingual teacher, I can um see some
friendly faces from the past. This is
exceptional teaching. This is an
exceptional facility. unfortunate
situations. So, I'm gonna talk about the
elephant in the room. Do not mistake our
poise, our calmness, our um our kindness
for lack of caring. So, we have not
conducted ourselves in a way that other
campuses have. We have not crept into
other people's questions. We're not
going to be on the news, but we care
very deeply about our kids. We accept
what's happening. Yes, it's a proposal.
I'm I I accept it. Money is money. So
moving forward respectfully, I need you
to answer and be very very thought. You
need to think forward on all of these
things as it comes from a financial
perspective. I am so far removed from
TEA, from the school district, from
pedigogy, all of those things. I can't
speak to the quality and the excellence
of your plan, but you have trust here a
little bit. It's hanging on by a thread.
is your plan. You need to make sure the
plan you have put forth is going to
serve the students. We're going to get
out of this hole because financially
speaking, we cannot distract our board.
We cannot distract ourselves with
preserving locations, having we all want
affordable housing. There are other
areas and entities that that is what
they deal in. You all deal in educating
our children and preparing them for the
future call college or career ready. I
need you all to stay singularly focused
on that. I need you all to not get
distracted by all of this background
noise and you need to control all of
that. Shut it down. Choose equity. Lean
into what is right.
Lean into it, please, because this is we
are giving you our best and our
brightest. And we will trust and we will
go one more space, but then after that,
you're going to lose a lot of people.
So, I don't know exactly what my
question is, but I'm just saying we will
go on this journey with you.
This one feels very different than 2018
when Paul was leading it. I was working
on the east side. It I understand how
equity is at the center of what we're
doing here, but let's stay very focused
that it's children, it's quality
teachers, quality leaders, caring and
loving communities. I'm not saying that
those other schools aren't caring and
loving, but these people are the real
deal. We've been This is it. We've
helped turn this around.
When you gave us that ridiculous
previous administrator, we went on that
journey and we stayed in the car. We
didn't run away to private schools. We
didn't go to a charter. We're here.
So, please take that very seriously. Do
not get distracted in this final final
hour. You've made the plan. Stick to the
plan. Stomp it down. Move forward. And
please don't ever ask us for any more
bond money. No more money. Like take
your your budget that you have just like
we have our household budgets. Take it
and make it work. Okay. Thank you, sir.
>> Well, I mean, so
>> you have to respond.
>> I Well, you have a trustee in the room,
so I think it's I I think it's
just
I just I I want you to know I want our
community and our staff to know that it
is a very
multi-layered plan and it has to be to
address all the weights in the risks
that we're managing and I am very
committed to having a plan move forward.
Um there are lots of pressures, there
are lots of things occurring around the
community. I am committed to listening
and refining. I am telling everybody
that will hear me, we have to make a
decision and move forward. The longer
that this lingers, the more of an impact
it's going to have on all of our
students as they start the 2627 school
year, the less time that we have to
support enrollment procedures and it's
going to create frustration in our
community. I cannot take away the one
thing that I have to give our families
and that's time to plan. So, I'm
committed to doing that. Yes, there are
lots of pressures. I appreciate you
sharing that. Um it's hard. Um but I
love this community and we have to do
something. Uh we just we have to evolve.
We just absolutely have to. And so um I
do think this plan uh moves us in a very
good direction. I've spent so much time.
There are obviously going to be
opportunities to refine and improve, but
it's all going to be execution. Like if
I do not execute the plan, it would have
been a tremendous amount of resources,
energy, and pain and be right back here
in four years. That is not what I'm
going to do. I won't be part of that.
Like we we have to get through it and we
have to implement well. So I appreciate
that comment probably more than you
know.
>> My name is Christian. My daughter's been
here all five years. Oh, sorry. I just
want to like yell the mic. U one of the
things I did want to ask is that AIC
freeze the closure for at least 12
months.
>> Oh, I'm sorry. Is that good?
>> Yes.
>> Um did want to ask you the AIC freeze
the closure for 12 months. uh and
classify. Obviously, Dawson is the home
campus for my daughter. Um I'm
advocating for this campus specifically,
but also surrounding campuses.
Obviously, can't save all 13
specifically. Um it is a financial
issue, not really a location issue. Um
>> I'm sorry.
>> Oh, I'm sorry.
>> Um
>> to me, I'll do it.
>> No, you're good. Um my big thing is that
it's more of a rush process overall. Um,
obviously with having minimum amount of
time obviously creates distrust in
community, anything that's rushed, you
know, accusations are going to get
thrown out there. I'm more of a
solutions person. Uh, one of the things
I did want to ask about, um, try to be
very quickly and concise with my, uh,
statements. I know that there's bond
allocated funds for a lot of these
schools that are closing.
>> Um, obviously they're going to be
repurposed. Um, I would ask obviously
take a deep look at that. I'm sure you
all have. um and add that into one to
five specific campuses um to try to save
the bulk of the students. Um the
reasoning thing I was looking at as far
as helping out would be u for South
Austin specifically as a recovery zone
for um specifically St. Elmo's Galindo
Joselyn and obviously Dawson as a home
campus. Um I was going to see about a 1%
increase in your ADA attendance for
Dawson would generate about $20,000 per
year. um you know looking at as across
the board I know there are some campuses
that are based on not necessarily
attendance but enrollment um that does
add funds if that is that a mistake or
yeah because I know that
>> it's just every single campus is an ADA
per um and then I was going to ask about
as well uh weighted funding u for
specific students obviously with it
being mainly bilingual community a lot
of these campuses um there's a lot of
funds that are available as well as uh
reaching out testing kids for GT
um because that does add a lot of
funding for the campuses as well. Um is
that something that y'all have have
looked at doing?
>> Oh yeah. Um so so great question. I
don't want to stop you, sir.
>> No, go ahead.
>> Uh so a couple things. The first thing I
would say is um from an average daily
attendance, which is how we um generate
revenue, right? It's the number of staff
students that you have. Not all students
are equal. Some students are 1.0, somes
are 1.25, somes are 0.5. like a a pre-K
student, we would only get half of that
allocation because we can only fund them
for half a day at prek3, right? Um and
then their attendance is multiplied if
it's 0.96 or you know 0.97. I will tell
you in the last year we have made a
significant effort to increase average
daily attendance. Last year we actually
increased by over 1% as a school
district generating millions of dollars.
So I have been hyperfocused on that. You
have to address chronic absenteeism to
get there. We've done that. uh when it
comes to um coding. So, one of our
initiatives is uh PES reform. Uh PES is
an acronym that y'all don't need to know
about necessarily, but what it does is
it helps us code students correctly so
that we can get reimbursed from the
state to um in a in an accurate way. I
would say that three years ago that
system was not what it needed to be and
we were leaving millions and millions of
dollars on the table. So, in 23 24 we
went through an ERP transition. We've
done a lot of training with our teachers
and educators and so the coding has
improved and so we'll get some of that
those funds back. As far as emerging
bilingual students or dual language by
law um we do get funds back from the
state. A percentage of those have to be
spent um on those students or those
student populations and we do that. We
also spend more uh just to be clear like
one of the reasons that we are where we
are is because we've elected to educate
a certain way. uh and those things are
more above and beyond what the state
kind of funds us for. Uh the last thing
uh that you mentioned was um gifted and
talented. So one of the things that we
also do as a board is we're tracking
where our students are, where do we have
um misalignments by uh student
population. So like our African-American
students um are disproportionately under
gifted and talented percentages. So,
we've been focusing on bringing that
number up, which means that we need to
educate ourselves and our principles and
our staff to to identify, have them um
test, be assessed, and then move them
in. And that number has also moved. So,
we are doing those things. I promise
you. I am turning over like every
cushion that exists in Austin ISD to to
figure out how to bring all of this
together. You said something around um
rushed. I would use the arg I would say
urgent. Um it I know that it feels it
feels rushed. Um, I would say that the
plan, the detail in it, the work like
like to get to that point, it takes time
and we've been doing that work since
February of last year. Um, and it also
builds on other efforts. 2022 long range
plan, 2017 bond, the equity assessment,
there are so many things that allowed us
to start from a good place opposed to
starting from nothing. Um, but the
reality of it all is if we miss these
windows of opportunity, then you're
waiting a whole year. and and and so
that's just, you know, kind of my my
position on the urgency versus rush, but
I understand why it feels that way.
>> Uh, one of the other things I was going
to ask about as well, I know recently,
uh, I know you actually kind of touched
on a little bit earlier, um, Dallas ISD,
>> yeah, in up in that area, they did
recapture uh, money from the state uh,
for a Medicare program. I know AIC has
historically not taken advantage of
those funds. Um I believe the name of
the program, sorry about that, is the
I'm gonna I'll just spell out the
acronym because I don't want to mess up
is SH RS. Yeah. SHs. Yeah. So SHs um so
we are the biggest So that's another
one. So we are the we actually on a per
student basis and per um reimbursement
basis or greater um by student than any
other school district. I will tell you
again this is back to one of the
pressures that came up in 2425.
We had been budgeting $16 million in
reimbursement from the federal
government that goes through the state
right in 2425.
So just a year ago, uh one of the things
that happened was the federal government
and the state got into an argument
essentially about what can be funded and
what couldn't. We had to adjust our
budget down to 4 million. So, we lost
$12 million in one year because of how
the federal government and the state
kind of determine what gets reimbursed.
Well, those are direct dollars out of
our 199 which funds all teachers, all
principles, all programming. So, we
actually are one of the largest um uh um
school districts that that pursue that
and we have historically, but I will
tell you that it is not as shiny as it
has been in the past. it's going in the
wrong direction and that's a sorry but
that's what happened last year.
>> I just I want to make sure everyone
followed that because so chars is where
when we have educators who provide
certain services to students with
disabilities um historically we have
gotten reimbursed for some of those
services and so what what Matias is
explaining is that the types of services
that qualify for reimbursement have
significantly gone down to the tune of
12 million. I just want to make sure
that was understood by folks who weren't
following the stars conversation.
>> And then uh one of the last things I was
going to ask is I know the plan is right
now for Dawson to move to Galindo. Yes,
sir.
>> Um to reverse the flow of the students.
So I obviously I'm not going to I can't
advocate for every campus and this is my
home campus. Um my daughter's been here
all five years. They've improved every
single year. Um staff has been
wonderful. Um, but again, I think for as
far as a strategic location, the hub for
students, it's not going to be hard
either way. Um, but this campus kind of
provides a little more resources, open
space, [snorts] and uh, you know, as far
as transportation is also easier as
well.
>> Yeah.
>> Um,
>> you're talking about for like Gindo to
come here,
>> correct? Yeah. Just a vice versa flow
soon. I understand the programs at the
specific locations is probably a reason
why flowing there for moneywise, but so
programs are transferable. So I would
say the one thing I want to be really
really clear is the state of Texas would
never allow that. Um and the reason
being is because Galindo doesn't have
the same weight of the accountability
chain. And so when you think about
moving students um Galindo doesn't have
the three UAS. The state of the Texas
education agency would not ever approve
that turnaround plan because they would
see it as taking a a school that
historically performed and and wholly
moving that school into a school that's
underperformed. That's their view.
That's not my view. But that is why that
would not be a possible solution. I just
want to be really honest with with you.
Um and and that's why we wouldn't have
proposed it because I cannot propose
something that I know will not be
accepted. Is that helpful? It is. I was
going to say if it's there's obviously
criteria that have to meet and I'm sure
you're well aware of those criterias. Um
you know as say give it more time so you
can kind of edit and adjust accordingly.
So you can't justify that proposal. Um
because just from the transfer of
things, I think it build more trust with
the community. I mean, give us all the
things that have been thrown around as
far as values and things like that. Um
that would help out as far as, you know,
keeping a a rooted school in the
community as well as obviously garnering
some public trust uh and that action of
giving it a few more months to to find a
way around that that option.
>> Yeah. Um so the the months issue is hard
because I want to be clear, enrollment
and registration starts in November,
>> correct? Um, and I don't have we don't
have all the way until May or June. We
have to make the decisions. We have to
change our ent all of our internal
systems so that when our families go and
select where they want to enroll, we're
ready to receive them. We also have to
hire staff. This plan includes us
identifying the principles of all the
schools in December. They are then going
to hire their staff in uh January,
February, and March. And guess which
staff they're going to hire? they're
going to hire our staff first. If I wait
longer, then I'm going to compress all
of that work into a really short period
of time and we will not be successful.
The other thing I would say is we cannot
make a big change in the spring
semester. I my if we ever got to that
point, I would just say you have to push
it because we have seen changes occur in
the spring semester. We took sixth grade
music example because it's one that's
salient. We took sixth grade from Martin
and Mendes in April uh of 2022 for a 22
23 school year. We did not recover from
that. Moving those students, the
confusion it created in our community,
you know, having our staff get staffed
up, the certifications are different,
the resources, the rooms, all of those
things happened over the summertime cost
us incredible amount of money and it
never actually worked. Um, so again, I
have to have time for our families to
plan for us to prepare to receive
families. And I I do not want to put us
in a position where we're not going to
be successful to start a next school
year. So a delay effectively is a a
year. It's it wouldn't be just four or
five months because I I think that
sometimes comes up and I just want to be
really clear why November is so
important.
>> And sir, we have about 10 minutes left
and two people that was my last
question. Yeah.
>> Okay, perfect. And if you have other
questions, there's going to be a lot of
us that will be able to linger. Yeah.
Yeah.
Hi. Oh, sorry. Oh, hi. My name is
Shirley Roio and I just had a quick
question. I, you know, I had been part
of the process, all the changes that you
had tried, you know, to change these
statistics, but my own daughter comes
here. Um, my question is why
um what was your criteria? Why not to
put the um the the students in a school
where they can already get what they
really need and it's good quality
education. At the end we are going
through this hard process and it needs
to be worth like um we already know
Galindo is still a low performance
school and I love the students in here
and I want the best for my for my own
daughter. So I wonder why uh not to put
them already in a good quality school
and and also in order to keep the
community together. That's my question.
Yeah. Um so we always think about um pro
kind of couple things. First is
geographically are they close together?
We we never want to be in a position
where we move a school and then students
are having to bus across town. Like
we're not going to do that. That's
happened before in Austin IC. That's not
who we are. We think about schools that
have similar demographics.
Honestly, the demographics between
Galindo and Dawson are are are fairly
similar. And so when you think about
bringing communities together, it seems
as though it's a a um we could have and
with planning a very thoughtful
transition pro process. Uh regarding
academics, uh we think about movement of
students, right? So Travis Heights to
the east, you know, they they could not
receive Galind I mean Dawson whole. One
of the things that we talk about is
having community go together. And so I
had to find a solution that kept Dawson
together able was able to break the
accountability chain did not increase
cost necessarily or create inequities by
transporting students and that's why
this is a solution that we arrived at or
the recommend recommendation.
uh if there are others out there. Um you
know, we think about Joselyn or going
south of Ben White. Well, Ben White is a
big barrier in our community and we know
that we like to use those as boundaries
for our attendance boundaries. So, um
all of it kind of came into play. Uh so,
it was not any one thing, it was all of
them. Uh but we did list out what those
criteria were. But they're, you're
right, they're they're not all equal and
they're not all weighted the same way
for every solution. in some schools in
some consolidation it looks a little bit
different because there are other things
that were just weighed differently you
know our our schools are fixed you know
I think that's the biggest challenge we
have
>> I'm just going to add because our
operations officer shared so for this
area we have about 3,000 seats there's 1
1600 students and like Matias was saying
we wanted to try to keep schools
together there wouldn't be enough room
for all of Galindo to come to Dawson
right and like he said there's not
enough room at Travis Heights for all of
all of Dawson. So, it's it's kind of
like these puzzle pieces and the
different constraints that you have in
different areas that led to this
decision.
Wait, did you have a question? Go ahead.
>> Hi, my name is Ashley Loraca. I have two
kids at AISD. Um, and so my question is
about equality and transfers. What are
we doing with our transfer policy um
specifically to reduce the amount of
white flight that we have from our east
side schools? What are we doing there?
>> Yeah. So, uh a couple things um you're
going to see in this next upload
clear changes to our policies. Um a
couple things that we have already
changed um that and one that we will be
changing. The first is the uh uh
majority to minor minority to majority
transfer. Uh that was actually we're
proposing to pull that out. It was
should have been pulled out probably two
years ago. Um the other one is diversity
choice.
>> Uh diversity choice is a pol a transfer
policy that's been in place for probably
two three decades. Josh, I mean is that
about right? Uh and so huh
>> post civil rights era. And what it did
is there's the transfer in there that
says if you go to Mets Elementary
School, no matter what middle school you
go to, you can go to Austin High School,
right? There are lots of these really
kind of random like connections that
some of them don't even have the
schools. They don't exist that way
anymore. It's the names have changed. It
is an outdated transfer policy and many
of these transfer policies are used to
kind of attract students out of um parts
of town to other parts of town. But
there the other thing that I run into
from an equity perspective is if I have
a student who's been historically
underserved and they have access to a
higher performing school and I sever
that then am I taking away access from a
student who historically did not have
access. So for for me what I have to for
us what we have to do is to figure out I
need to provide the resources strengthen
the feeder patterns back to the
boundaries add the resources so that
those schools begin to perform um right
in a way that aligns with our values so
they don't feel like they have to go
right so so it's kind of a balance of
the two. If I if I just adjust the
transfer then they may go to a charter
they may go to some other place but I
want to keep them in Austin IC. I do
think Austin ISTD has the best education
uh for our students in Austin. There's
no doubt. And so for me, both have to be
addressed simultaneously, but we are
taking those transfers. We are going to
be suns setting them. And then also
adding detail around transfer policies
as it pertains to this work. Like if
you're um you know, if what what does a
sibling transfer look like if if a you
know, school consolidates, we're going
to make that very very clear. And I
think you'll see a lot of our changes be
responsive to what we've heard from the
community. But yeah, those are those are
coming off.
>> Thank you.
>> Um, we are at time, but if we can maybe
do like rapid fire just to get through
the last three questions. Do you have
time to say? Okay,
>> sure.
>> Hi, my name is Anna Lopez.
>> Thank you.
>> Yeah.
>> I'm the program manager with communities
and schools.
>> And I am particularly concerned about
our Mebrook community. I know we have a
large population here at Dawson
[clears throat] and at um Becker and I
know they're going to Silker Elementary,
a community that is very different from
what they're used to. So I want to know
how AISD is going to support that
transition, support those families. I
know they're coming from schools that
have CIS and have our support into a
nonCIS school. So what are y'all going
to do to help them and support them
more?
>> Yeah. Um, so we've looked at that
student population, the number of
students. Uh, there were plans at one
point that had them going to to Galindo.
You know, it kind of creates anomalies
in our boundary changes if we were to do
that. Uh, and we also know there are
lots of other parts of the city where
that exists already. Um, what we need to
do is to make sure that our teachers,
our principal and leaders at Zilker
understand the needs of these students,
have professional development in
anticipation of them coming and are
resourced to actually do it. Um I will
say that right now, you know, we're
working we have our transition plan
framework and it includes sections to
dive deeply into these um kind of areas
whenever they occur in a campus. We have
not built those out yet because we don't
quite have a vote because that work
would be led by our principles right in
support with the support of our
executive directors. So I'll tell you
we're thinking about it. um we have
different frameworks and strategies that
we would deploy but they're not built
out. So I can't tell you specifically
what we're doing because I would expect
that to occur with the leaders from
Zilker, the leaders from Galinda. I mean
that would occur with them in the room.
Um we're not just going to say hey this
is what you're going to do. What we want
to say is what do you need? How can we
responsive? Also these are some other
great practices that we think will work.
Um, but you will see that if the vote
takes place on the November 20th, you'll
see us work really, really hard through
the month of December into January and
and then release those so that everybody
understands through the spring semester
what we're doing to prepare for 2627. So
that's how we're going to tackle it.
>> Oh yeah. Sorry.
>> Hi. I just want to uplift that this is
the first school that we've been at that
has asked about how are we going to take
care of our children as they transition.
And so I really want to thank you for
that because that really speaks to a
human- centered designed approach. And
so um I first want to extend that
gratitude. We do have where's I wanted
to look in the face of the young lady
who asked the question. There you are.
Yes. Um so we have I want to start with
my name is Staca Pascal and I serve as
the director of strategic planning and
organizational effectiveness. Um we have
what's called a bridge team. And on our
bridge team, it's myself as well as our
executive director of student support
services, restorative practices, our
counselors, and our LMHPS. And so the
work that we're doing right now
alongside of all of what's happening is
thinking through how do we have this
beautiful merger of communities that
allow identities to remain intact while
forming something new.
We are very aware of various
demographics and the possible impacts of
bringing those together and thinking
through what professional learning would
be helpful. Um what are some things that
we're going to need to maybe touch back
up on? How do we go out and make
connections with the neighborhoods for
them to understand what new resources
are available? What resources aren't
available? Our LMHPS are creating one
pages of resources so families know I'm
used to going here but now I will be
here. And so those are things that are
happening and no one has asked about it.
So thank you so much for asking, but it
is a very thoughtful process that we're
doing alongside this work.
Okay. Hi, I'm Anastasia Alexander. I'm a
first grade dual language teacher here.
Um part of what drew me to the school
was that it was small and I was at a
campus that had merged and I did notice
that the merging of the cultures. I have
a similar question. it was kind of an us
and them um dynamic there. And so
hearing that you're going to take steps
is really helpful, but just kind of
making sure that can you guys check in
on the campuses to make sure it's
actually happening because I've been on
one
>> and wasn't wellreceived. Um and then I
also had a question about programming.
So we're a two-way campus and I know
that you're going wallto-all and so like
there are some students
>> um you said that Galindo had similar
programming but they just have a one-way
program, correct? And so will those
students that are currently in the 2-way
program that are um non-emergent
bilingual like will they have a place
for them?
>> Yeah. So fortunately our board policy
does allow for that right for students
that are participating or non-emergent
bilingual students that want to
participate in dual language programming
can do that. Um we've looked at the
numbers right of course it'll be
communication with the principal um at
Galindo but um there are seats right and
we welcome the students to come in. So
overall the the model looks the same in
a one way or two-way. The biggest change
is the participants that are in the
classrooms, right? Yes.
>> So we would be able to accommodate that.
When I looked at the numbers, it looks
like about 49 students that would be
moving. That would include our emergent
bilingual and non-emergent bilingual at
Dawson's.
>> Okay.
>> Okay. Thank you.
>> Um one comment on the merging. So when
the board took the vote in 2019 to I'm
assuming you're talking about one of
those schools. Uh okay. [laughter]
Um it was you know Met Sanchez, Norman
Sims, Brooke to Linder Anggo Valley as
well as um Peas. Yeah. Which kind of
distributed because they were
nonattendance boundary no attendance
boundary school. Um we created plans uh
but then in the spring the pandemic hit.
So so I want to be really clear. I
remember we we built the plans, we were
working the plans and then all of a
sudden spring break pandemic hits,
everybody's gone. And so that really
disrupted our approach. And so I'm not
surprised to hear that when we came back
and everybody was all together all of a
sudden that time needed to actually
build community to transition just got
sucked up in the vortex that was the
pandemic.
>> Um because I've heard that a lot and I
and I I was in the I was in the rooms
like I remember all these things
happening and what didn't happen was the
intentionality around the transition
plans because we were dealing with the
pandemic. That is a lesson learned. I
don't know that could have been avoided
but that is the single thing that
created that I think issue across our
system. We've learned from that which is
why these plans are going to be very
thoughtful and then I will absolutely be
tracking progress amongst all of these
plans. But that's one thing I just
wanted to point out because it's it's a
little ways back but that was the one
thing that really kept us from executing
>> because it wasn't just with the students
kind of not feeling welcome but with the
teachers as well you know. So thank you.
>> Sorry to hear that.
Hello. Hello. Uh, let me raise it really
quick. Um, my name is Rachel Smith. I'm
the uh, library services associate here.
Um, and I know at the beginning we kind
of talked about um, like teachers and
other staff getting positions in other
places. Um, I think specifically for
people who are in specials and
librarians and uh, principles who
there's just a not as many positions
available. Um, I know I'm a little
freaked out about having a future at
AISD. Um, it's something that I do want,
but what are you doing to kind of help
those positions transition? Because I
hear a lot of talk about the teachers
and there should be, but also for
specials, for oneoffs, like how are we
going to get that support too?
>> Yeah. No, so that it is very much a
focus of mine. What I will say is a
couple things.
I've heard this before, Matias, like the
numbers don't work.
>> And and that is true if you're not
thinking about retirements, if you're
not thinking about all the other
elements that we have within our
district, including um different
students moving and being promoted into
other positions. So, across all of our
positions, specifically when it comes to
principles, which is like an area of
focus for mine, but our executive
directors with everybody else, it's
identifying where are we going to have
known movement. We know right now our
can tell you right obviously I can't
tell you but I have an understanding of
which principles are retiring uh which
principles have said you know Matias
like I'm going to I'm going to consider
something else or which principles may
move into executive leadership positions
like these two over here were principles
last year and they're fantastic and so
we that is that is my job right my job
is to make sure I have an understanding
of all of it so that I can um create
opportunities for um anybody that may be
transitioning so um I don't want you to
leave this meeting thinking that a we're
not thinking about it or b there won't
be a space for you. In the event that
there isn't a similar position that you
like or that you want. Um I will also
say that I'm freezing all positions
right so that you know you will have a
home uh and we will protect you know
elements um of your existing kind of the
how you you know kind of your exist I
don't want to that's a talent human
capital talent strategy thing but I what
I'll say is I am doing everything
possible to create as many landing spots
as many opportunities but focusing on
where you are and what you want to do
the survey that our staff are going to
get is going to be absolutelyant
important that you fill it out and you
share with us exactly what you want.
There have been teachers who've told me,
Matias, I've been in South Austin for 15
years, but I actually live in
Flugerville. Can you help me find a a
transition to a school in North Austin?
It won't be one of the ones that's here.
It'll be a school that's just hiring
staff. Like, we can do all those things.
We hire 700 staff every year. It's not
just teachers. It's teacher assistants.
It's labor technicians. It's everybody.
So, um please share with us. Uh we're
doing everything possible. I want you to
stay in Austin ISD. It's important that
you stay in Austin ISD. Uh, and so, um,
you know, hopefully as you see this
progress, you'll see more detail about
what you can expect, but we are
absolutely thinking about all staff, not
just teachers and principles. It's
classified staff. You heard me. I mean,
I said less a whole bunch of them, but
yes, that's how we're tackling it.
>> One more question. Um, I know we're
talking about the transition for the
kids, um, and how that's going to be
really hard. Um, just like a quick
experience I had with one of the kids
specifically in regards to like the TAP
programming. Um, I had a kid be like,
"Oh, are we closing?" And I was like,
"Yes, we are." Uh, most likely. Um, and
then he asked me if it was because
they're stupid. And that's something
that's really painful for me to hear as
an educator. Um, and you know, I do my
best to reiterate, no, it's not that.
There's a system in play that's against
you and it's not it's not your fault in
the least. Um, and so I just want to ask
slash hope that um that like are y'all
going to be able to support our students
in some way to kind of help them right
now?
>> Yeah,
>> it's a great question.
>> I can't express enough gratitude for
that. Right. Um, the approach that we
use in this work is transformative
social emotional learning. And so how
are we ensuring that there is not an
attachment to my identity to what's
happening in the circumstances around
me? Um we've started with some
processing circles with staff and so
that's something that will continue to
happen. And then we're also looking at
what makes the most sense for each
community. Is it us helping a teacher
who already has a relationship with
students to facilitate this processing
space with students? Is it us coming in
and doing that for them? Is it the LMHP?
Is it the counselor? Um, we are crafting
lessons that can be used in advisory.
We're uh crafting morning circles to
have this processing take place. And so
all of these things will be made
available to be used in during this
school year, not waiting until
afterwards, but we are waiting on where
do we need to deploy these levels of
support after the vote.
Well, thank you so much everyone. Um, I
just want to particularly to your
comment like Matia said, I don't think
that you maybe realize how much that
comment means to us just hearing that
y'all are recognizing the position that
we're in and are willing to take this
step with us and I want you to know that
that we really appreciate that because
we know that there's been a fair number
of disappointments and challenges. Um,
and so I hope that you have heard and
can see that we're working to very hard
to course correct so that we are not in
this position again. Um, but I just want
to go over the kind of we're in this
last phase of the process, but just so
everyone's familiar with the um stage
that we're in. Um, we are we have
actually I think Matias mentioned
earlier we have a board workshop this
Wednesday. That was something that was
recently added. So that at that meeting
if you want to tune in, they will kind
of be discussing a lot of what we've
heard from the comment cards, a lot of
the things the trustees are hearing that
they're wanting us to discuss kind of
publicly. Um so that's just going to be
an opportunity for you to see and
anticipate what changes um might be
taking place because we are actually re
releasing a revised version of the draft
this Friday. Um and that revised version
will be discussed the following Thursday
um at a board meeting. Um, and then as I
mentioned earlier, that final vote is
anticipated for November 20th. So, we're
continuing to refine. We will be pushing
out communication via email, text,
media, social media for you to be able
to see kind of more specifics. In that
draft plan, there were a lot of things
that we got questions about, we needed
clarity on or we were asked to refine.
And so, you'll be able to see and we're
it's going to be actually in a different
color text. So, you'll be able to see
what was originally shared and then what
how we've changed or revised. Um, and
last but not least, um, you have these
at your table. This comment card, it
does close, uh, tomorrow. So, um, if you
haven't put in your feedback, please get
it in there that we are, as you can
hopefully see through this meeting, um,
reviewing every single comment we've had
and when we release on Friday, we'll be
sharing kind of some of the themes that
we heard. And I think that you'll be
able to see that how the changes in the
plan are reflective of a lot of the
things that we heard in the comment
cards. Um, so I'm just going to ask, did
you want to say any parting words? Um,
just uh I very much appreciate y'all
coming out this morning. Um, you know,
this is difficult. Uh, I want you to
know that we as a school district, we we
view ourselves as much part of this, all
communities as well. Many of us have
staff and our in these schools. Um, so I
just thank you for coming out. Um, we we
are going to do everything possible to
ensure that this transition, if it does
go this way, supports you and your
families and your students. Uh, it's
hard. We never wanted to be here. I hope
we're never here again. Um, but we're
trying to do it the right way. Um, so
thank you. Appreciate y'all's time this
morning.
>> Thank you everybody for coming this
morning. Thank you for your support. I
know that we have been together through
all these four years and we'll continue
this year.
We have done a lot a lot uh when we
[applause]
We have an internal joke about our
scores because yes, when I took the
school, we were in the low 50s and
little by little we have been inching
in. We were at a 59 internally and then
finally stayed 58. So our internal joke
is, is it a strong F? Yes, it is a
strong F because of you. Thank you.